since canvas is an online portal it is  vital for students and teachers to have  access to the internet  for some families across the valley  that's not always possible  ccsd is trying to meet that demand as  well it's giving chromebooks to students  who need them and  it's also turning the school buses into  mobile wi-fi hot spots  the buses are driving into neighborhoods  with poor connectivity  allowing students to log on for classes  and school work  if you still need to get your student  your child connected or you need a  chromebook for class  just contact the family support center  we have the number at the bottom of your  screen 888-616-2476